Давайте зробимо Місяць ближчим разом.
Це не віртуальна гра або вигадана фантазерами 3D-проекція майбутнього поселення на Місяці.
І ці люди - не геймери, а українські розробники реальної місячної
промислово-дослідницької станції, де можуть перебувати одночасно майже 100 людей,
в тому числі космічні туристи.
Перший модуль місячної бази, в який ми потрапляємо, - шлюзовий.
Космонавт заходить, з нього знімається абразивний місячний пил
спеціальною магнітною аркою, тому що місячний пил усе псує.
В американців, коли вони літали на Місяць, з цим були дуже великі проблеми.
35-річна Юлія Лисенко та 30-річний Михайло Каляпін -
керівники кількох наукових груп дніпровського Конструкторського бюро "Південне".
Понад три роки вони займалися детальним аналізом і проектуванням усього,
що зараз можна побачити за допомогою VR-окулярів.
Починаючи з того, де і як виробити ці житлово-промислові модулі,
та як комплектуючі для них доправити з Землі,
і головне: зробити це силами української промисловості та науки.
У нас є лінійка розроблених так званих лендерів, які доправляють вантажі на Місяць.
На майбутнє опрацьована концепція багаторазового місячного лендера,
який буде дозаправлятися місячним паливом, виробленим із місячної криги,
і закінчуючи тим, скільки разів треба буде надсилати екіпажі
з 4-х людей до Місяця, аби збудувати станцію у 5 етапів,
та як космонавтам та дослідникам створити земні умови для існування.
Не треба буде цей помідор або ще щось тягти з Землі.
У перспективі станція має перейти на повне самозабезпечення,
тобто виробляти всі необхідні для життя компоненти: їжу, кисень - безпосередньо на Місяці.
Юлія та Михайло захоплюються наукою і космосом із дитинства.
Юлія має за плечима серію наукових публікацій,
зокрема в відомих міжнародних космічних виданнях.
Михайло встиг запатентувати кілька своїх розробок.
Ці молоді вчені - перспективні співробітники не тільки для конструкторського бюро,
а й для іноземних роботодавців. В останні роки у світовій космічній галузі не вщухає
справжня війна за мізки вчених. Втім, ці вчені з Дніпра своє наукове майбутнє
у подібних місячних проектах за межами України - у США чи ЄС - поки не бачать.
Конкретно мені таких пропозицій не надходило.
Але, як каже мій шеф, я - патріот КБ "Південне". Можливо, це через спадкоємність поколінь.
Але це моя усвідомлена позиція, що в нас тут, у КБ,
збереглася, можна сказати, оаза для молодих спеціалістів.
За кордон я не хочу переїжджати. Я - патріот України.
Юля - патріот КБ "Південне", а я, як мінімум, патріот України.
У майбутньому я себе бачу більш кваліфікованим
та затребуваним фахівцем ракетно-космічної галузі.
КБ "Південне" має багаторічний досвід космічних досліджень
і теж проводить постійний пошук молодих талановитих вчених.
Тут шукають таланти у школах, серед студентів, проводячи конкурси винахідників
із доволі пристойними преміями, пропонують роботу ще на 3-4 курсі.
Із найкращих обирають майбутніх співробітників.
Для перспективних будують житло і надають його на пільгових фінансових умовах.
Заробітна платня в бюро - в середньому не менше 15 тисяч гривень.
Можуть бути ще й непогані надбавки у вигляді премій
відповідно до інтелектуальних зусиль вченого чи вченої
в роботі над комерційним міжнародним проектом.
КБ "Південне" заробляє кошти, приміром, беручи участь у таких проектах, як "Антарес" і "Вега".
Тих, хто не досяг 35-річного віку - таких співробітників у нашому штатному розкладі
приблизно 30% при тому, що в нас загалом трохи більше 5 тисяч людей
працює і середній вік по факту на минулий місяць -  46 років.
При цьому є й технічний відтік. Від нас ідуть,
переманюють хороші кадри, ми також переманюємо звідкись хороші кадри.
Це нормальний процес. У нас постійно працює відділ кадрів,
постійно є вакансії для молодих спеціалістів особливо.
Випадків, коли ключових співробітників переманювали
наукові центри за кордон, каже Максим Дегтярьов, у КБ не було.
І ситуація така, що бажаючих потрапити сюди на роботу завжди більше, ніж КБ у змозі взяти.
І це дає можливість не відчувати дефіциту інтелектуальних ресурсів.
Молоді вчені фактично перебувають у процесі своєрідного інтелектуального змагання.
Секрет цього, схоже, у самих проектах, які розробляє і впроваджує КБ "Південне".
Завершуються випробування космічного апарату СІЧ 2.1,
запуск якого має відбутися наступного року.
На цей час Україна не має жодного супутника дистанційного зондування Землі на орбіті
й вимушена отримувати знімки з іноземних апаратів
і витрачати десятки мільйонів бюджетних коштів.
За допомогою цього супутника Україна зможе моніторити, приміром, стихійні лиха –
повені та пожежі - і вчасно на них реагувати.
Супутник також дуже потрібен армії задля контролю ситуації на кордонах.
Цей супутник розробили молоді вчені Дніпра за кошти КБ "Південне".
Тут розраховують, що їхні зусилля не будуть марними,
адже якщо супутник упродовж двох років не буде виведено на орбіту,
то його треба буде оновлювати.
Це підтвердить статус України як космічної держави
та надасть можливість для розвитку космічних технологій в Україні.
Юлія і Михайло теж розуміють, що поки в держави немає фінансових ресурсів
на створення місячної станції. Втім, якщо Україна ризикне це зробити,
то забезпечить роботою українські заводи та інститути на багато років.
Повністю ми все можемо зробити, в принципі, за належного фінансування.
Щоб усе це реалізувати, потрібно доволі багато грошей.
За приблизними розрахунками, близько 170 мільярдів доларів лише одноразових витрат.
Реалізація амбітних проектів КБ "Південне", переконані молоді вчені з Дніпра,
можлива, якщо буде затверджено державну програму з розвитку космічних технологій
та освоєння космосу з відповідним фінансуванням.
Наразі подібні амбіції має Державне космічне агентство.
Михайло та Юлія радять посадовцям поквапитися.
Адже 2030 рік, за їхнім аналізом, може стати роком масової появи на Місяці
станцій та цілих містечок. Світова гонка за лідерство в цьому триває,
і якщо Україна не візьме у ній активну участь, то молоді українські вчені
не матимуть іншого шансу, як залишити країну.